Moe was also a historic date night for
Prince Harry and making marshmallows the
two hosted a charity performance of the
musical Hamilton and everybody is
talking about two things
Meghan's leg yes and wait for this Harry
singing boys retirees steals the show
but sorry no encore
the line Harry built it out is actually
part of a song sung by King George and
musical Hamilton who happens to be
Prince Harry's great-great-great
great-great great-grandfather
but last night eyes were also on
Meghan's little black dress and a
potential mini royal scandal the judith
and charles digital tuxedo dress that
hit above Meghan's knee is considered by
some a bad representation of thore
Orioles and breaks an unofficial royal
rule that women in the family do not
wear clothes that show any knee the son
headline read the king and thigh you'll
even notice the official Kensington
Palace Instagram account posted the
couples night out by not showing her
entire dress
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]